- [Voiceover] Hey Becca!
- [Voiceover] Hey Kim!
- [Voiceover] Alright, so
we're talking about how people
got to the Americas today.
So when did people first
arrive in North America?
Was Columbus the first one?
- [Voiceover] So, no he was not.
You know, back in the day people believed
that actually pre-Columbus
no one was here,
but in this video I'm
not going to be talking
about if, right?
There definitely were people here,
but I'll be talking about
how people got here,
when, and who they were.
And so these are the
questions that historians
and archaeologists are
still debating today.
So Kim who are archaeologists?
(chuckling)
- [Voiceover] Well
archaeologists are scholars
who work in the lands.
They will dig in the places
where people lived in the past,
find remains of earlier civilizations,
and use that evidence to build a picture
of what life was like in a place
before there was a written record.
- [Voiceover] So a lot of
the history we'll talk about
in this video has to do
with different evidence
and competing evidence that
archaeologists have found
in the lands that we now
call the United States.
So as I mentioned, we're
not arguing if there
were people here because
there definitely were.
There were even big cities
and towns and people living
together in societies that look a lot like
what the colonists were
trying to make as well.
- [Voiceover] Yeah I
think people often have
the misconception that Native
Americans were primarily
hunter-gatherers who pretty
much lived in very small bands
that didn't leave much
of a record of buildings
or living sites, they were more nomadic.
But people were all over
North America and they had
societies that were very
different from each other,
some of which were very
complex politically,
and some of which were quite large cities.
This city here is Cahokia, which is--
- [Voiceover] That's a
fun thing to say, Cahokia.
- [Voiceover] (giggles) Yeah, I know.
I love the name Cahokia.
Close to modern-day St. Louis,
this was the largest city in the Americas.
About 40,000 to maybe 60,000
people lived in this city.
It's gonna be the largest
city in the Americas
until the 1780s when
Philadelphia has more people.
- [Voiceover] Wow, that
is just really remarkable.
So 40,000 people here in Cahokia,
and there were still
historical records that said
that there was no one here?
- [Voiceover] (giggling) Well
you know, history is something
that is highly influenced
by the kind of narratives
that historians wanna tell.
We know that humans as a
species today originated
somewhere in Africa and then
spread throughout Europe
and Asia to other land masses.
So how did they get to the
North American continent?
- [Voiceover] So we don't know for sure,
but archaeologists and historians
have pretty much agreed
that the Native Americans
came through the Bering Strait
which is as you can see right here.
This was like this big ice
sheet during the Ice Age
that connected Asia and
North America through Alaska.
So the Native Americans came from Asia,
they were Asian really,
and they walked across the Bering Strait
and down into North America.
- [Voiceover] What is
now water at that time
was covered with ice.
So I'm guessing they're
following herds of animals
that they might like to eat.
- [Voiceover] Yes, exactly,
and these were called the Paleo-Indians,
so they were the first Indians.
Paleo-Indians really means ancient people.
So these were the ancient
people and they were, again,
following different animals.
So historians estimate that
the Paleo-Indians came down
through the Bering Strait
about 13,000 years ago, so--
- [Voiceover] Wow!
- [Voiceover] It was a long time ago.
But now different archaeological
evidence may point
to the Paleo-Indians coming
over much earlier than that,
actually more like 16,000 years ago.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I mean 3,000 years is
a significant difference.
I mean think about 3,000
years earlier than today,
we'd be talking 1000 B.C.E.
- [Voiceover] So today
archaeologists and historians
kind of argue about when exactly it was,
and lots of different evidence and fossils
and archaeological digs
are coming up with evidence
that points us more
toward 16,000 than 13,000.
So it was actually in
1925 when archaeologists
found the first Clovis point.
So they're called Clovis
points because in 1925
archaeologists found
these kinds of arrowheads.
They're very small,
probably nothing more than
like two centimeters,
but they found them in Clovis, New Mexico,
so over here in New Mexico,
and estimated that they
were about 13,000 old.
So that's kind of our old hypothesis,
that humans were hunting
with these Clovis points
13,000 years ago,
probably buffalo or bison,
or any other kind of larger
animal that they would need
to carve out of stone
these arrowheads to shoot,
with a bow and arrow most likely,
these larger animals to eat.
- [Voiceover] So this is
some of the first evidence
that leads archaeologists
to an interpretation
of when human habitation first
occurred in North America?
- [Voiceover] Exactly and this
was kind of the overwhelming
consensus for really long time.
All throughout the 1900s
people are digging up
different artifacts all
across North America,
finding more Clovis points
and kind of all agree
it was about 13,000 years
ago that they came, again,
down through here and all around,
and that's why we were
finding these Clovis points.
But then in 1997, not too
long ago at all, actually,
so a Vanderbilt archaeologist,
his name is Tom Dillehay,
found evidence of humanity in
Chile, all the way down here.
So it seemed like the humans were living
about 14,000 years ago.
So it would have only
taken them a thousand years
to get all the way from up here down here.
So now there's kind of
two competing hypotheses.
Either they traveled by land
through the Bering Strait
and got all the way down here
in just a thousand years,
by foot, I mean they were really moving.
Or they actually were using
some sort of maritime vessel
to get down, they were in a boat.
But there's just these
small different theories
within this archaeological
movement about exactly how
they moved about and exactly when.
There's also this new
branch of DNA science
which is enlightening
historians about who the first
Native Americans were and who
their direct ancestors are.
- [Voiceover] These Paleo-Indians,
they're coming from Alaska,
they're coming from
Siberia I guess up there,
so are their direct
ancestors Russians, Asians?
- [Voiceover] The DNA evidence
points that the Paleo-Indians
were most closely related to the Asians.
They moved through Asia and
down through the Bering Strait.
- [Voiceover] Interesting,
so that kinda corraborrates
the archaeological record, right?
If we say that somewhere
between 10 and 16,000 years ago
there was a splintering of this population
from the Asian population.
The Bering Strait became water again,
and now in sort of classic
Darwin fashion we have
two separated populations
evolving differently.
- [Voiceover] Exactly,
and the DNA definitely
corraborrates that evidence.
So today archaeologists and DNA scientists
are working together to
figure out really which
of these hypotheses is more true.
Did they move by land or was it by water?
And they wanna learn more
about exactly who were they?
Yeah, they were Asian but how
did they distance themselves
from the rest of the
East Asian population?
Really, what motivated
them to come down through
the Bering Strait and
explore this territory?
- [Voiceover] One thing that
I think is really important
to take away from this is that
if you look at the history
of the Americas, you
start 16,000 years ago,
and the history of
Europeans in America is just
a tiny fraction of that time,
so the history of America
starts long before 1776,
long before 1492.
It starts when the first
people came to America
15,000 years ago.
- [Voiceover] Exactly, and
the Paleo-Indians started
their own American history
much before Columbus
sailed the ocean blue in 1492, right?
(giggling)
And archaeologists are
continuing to learn more
about the first Americans
and really the beginning
of American history.